-Our next guest earned
two Grammy nominations
for Best Folk Album and
Best American Roots Performance.
Performing
"Life According to Raechel"
from her album "Revealer,"
here's Madison Cunningham.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Once your girl ♪
♪ I'm always your girl ♪
♪ When I'm here
or when I'm there ♪
♪ Or on a plane
headed somewhere ♪
♪ You were staring
down the cars ♪
♪ Hoping it would be
one of ours ♪
♪ Children and grandchildren
writing you cards ♪
♪ But how long
were you waiting for me ♪
♪ To make a left
down your street? ♪
♪ It's not if, darling,
it's when ♪
♪ Was there something
left unsaid? ♪
♪ Were your eyes green? ♪
♪ Were they blue? ♪
♪ What was it that I forgot
to ask you? ♪
♪ Busy hands,
I'll set 'em down ♪
♪ To say I love you
right out loud ♪
♪ I'll bet you're making
heaven laugh ♪
♪ But it feels
like tears and memories ♪
♪ Are all ♪
♪ We have ♪
♪♪
♪ Once I knew it ♪
♪ I was always a know-it-all ♪
♪ Too busy, too stressed out ♪
♪ To take your call ♪
♪ Thought I would always
find you there ♪
♪ Sitting in your TV chair ♪
♪ While time is in a bar ♪
♪ Having a laugh somewhere ♪
♪ The nurse said
you were waiting for me ♪
♪ To let go, to let it be ♪
♪ It's not if, darling,
it's when ♪
♪ There's always something
left unsaid ♪
♪ Were your eyes green? ♪
♪ Were they blue? ♪
♪ What was it
that I forgot to ask you? ♪
♪ Busy hands,
I'll set 'em down ♪
♪ To say I love you
here and now ♪
♪ I'll bet you're making
heaven laugh ♪
♪ But it feels like
tears and memories ♪
♪ Are all ♪
♪ We have ♪
♪ Once your girl ♪
♪ I'm always your girl ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]